[Musique]
Salut est équipé d'une caméra qui filme
devant
l'entrée du salut et ensuite il y a un
écran ordinateur qui fait une analyse
avec une intelligence artificielle et en
fonction de ce qu'il y a des espèces
ciblée ou non ciblée il va se mettre en
mode pêche ou en mode vol
[Musique]
que veut dire que s'il y a des espèces
non simulé comme le chinchard parents
trop fort un bon avant dans le pêcheur
pourrait être informé en temps réel et
activer des dispositifs d'échappement
dans le chalut
[Musique]
Intersport de d'avoir le poisson sur le
fond sur le Pompidou et trier une fois
qu'il est mort donc je préfère le trier
sur le fond c'est pour ça que ce projet
intéressant parce que on sait à tout
moment ce qui rentre dans le filet
du poisson est l'espèce et si
on peut ouvrir ou fermer la trappe
[Musique]